now we come to the last but the most
critical move of the Whitewater
which is the move Bishop to f4 this move
specially played if you playing against
a very higher rated opponent or people
who know that you are going to play the
Colorado gambit and prepare this line
with the help of engines if you are
going to play the Colorado gambit then
you should know this more I am certainly
going to show you the most interesting
reply by the black well here black has
the only one good move and that keep the
black initiative alive and that is the
move Queen to b4 check the Queen to b4
check has a very simple idea queen wants
to grab the bishop and also attacking
the b2 so white response is pretty much
force one has to play Knight to c3
afterwards we are bravely capture the
beat upon and here white has a few
options now the main move is Bishop to
b2 and that's the mainline but before we
go to the mainline of course we have to
look at the side news and how we are
going to deal with it the first move I
am going to look at is the Bishop cross
c6 line against this of course black has
to capture this Bishop and now this
Knight is hanging as the most of the
games I have played in this line I have
reached this position two times and both
the times my opponent has played Knight
to a4 which looks very logical because
it's attacking the Queen and here I
played the move Queen to b5 so attacking
the knight as well as stopping Y to
castle on the King side so now again Y
response is pretty much forced y doesn't
want to play move such as c3 and make
the position very passive so again Y has
to keep the initiative so white played
Knight to c3 attacking my queen and here
I responded with Queen to a5 attacking
the knight one more time so there drive
that Bishop back to the
- and now I played the move Queen to a6
so again it has a dual purpose move it's
not only stopping the y2 castling on the
kingside but also protecting the c6 pawn
my opponent responded with the move rook
to be one and I just carried out my
normal pace development with the movie 6
and here I put and find nothing better
than Queen to e2 afterwards I simply
exchange the Queen and after King
recaptures I played the move C file so
immediately hitting the white center
quite capture this pawn and after I
recapture
now Bishop cross c2 is looming my
opponent has to deal with the threat so
he played the move Knight to d3 instead
of 9 to d3 in second game my opponent
responded with the move rook to b7 but
afterwards this group traps forever
so I played Bishop to b6 and my
opponent's idea was to play Knight to B
Phi and he thought that my King cannot
go to the d8 because Knight folk is
looming but he forgot about this move it
is castle and now that look is a collar
so that's why I wrote to b7 it's a not
at all good move so here my opponent
responded with the move Knight to d3
which has a mallet of attacking the
bishop so I dropped my bishop back to
the b6 and now my opponent played Knight
to e4 so he desperately want the bishop
path and here I just castle on the Kings
side and now my opponent grabbed the
bishop path and I recaptured with the a
pawn
the game continues like this so my upon
responded with rook to be - I played
look to a four and after f3 which has a
matter of stopping my knight coming to
either efore or the g4 I simply double
my rook on the file also it hit the pawn
on e2 so my opponent defended with the
move rook - even I simply play the move
Knight to d7 so it has a cunning idea
which first of all black wants to
capture this Knight and afterwards this
night will reroute from ePHI to the c4
my opponent here responded with the move
Bishop to c3 afterwards I played the
move e5 and now my opponent played the
blunder more which is the move Knight to
before now the game become very easy for
me so I played the Moody for attacking
the bishop and after Bishop goes back I
played the move Bishop to e6 now white
no longer can hold on to that pawn
because black is threatening to play the
move c5 which drive this night away and
then black is going to capture this
so that is how you can play against
Bishop cross c6 second move I want to
consider is Knight cross c6 afterwards
Black has to play this move which is the
move a six
here I have few games for you so in one
of my game my upon responded with move
Bishop to e4 and against this I capture
this night and after my opponent
responded with the move Bishop to d2 I
calmly played queen to see for stopping
why to castle on the kingside and not
only that it's also hitting this two
pieces so my response is pretty much
forced White has to play the move Knight
to d4 and now I played the move be fine
so hitting this Bishop and after Bishop
to b3 I just simply capture this pawn
and you can already see white is a to
pawn down further grimm goes like this
so my opponent castle on the kingside i
played the movie 6 fortunately this
moves also hitting the night so my
opponent has to deal with this Knight
afterwards i simply develop my bishop
and get it on the kingside castle and if
black can manage to King side castle
then white position is hopeless so there
is about Bishop to a for the another
tricky move I can try at this position
is rook to be one attacking the Queen
and again black response is pretty much
force so black has to capture this night
and after Bishop to d2 black can play
the move Queen to e3 and here I have the
two exciting game for you so in one of
my game
my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to b4 hitting the Queen and I
just capture the a to pawn and now I'm
threatening to capture the c2 pawn and
please note at this position whites 2
pcs are also hanging so in this game
my opponent decided to do
rook to e1 chasing my queen and his idea
was that once I capture the c2 white we
capture the Queens afterwards why play
the move Knight to e4 the spawn is right
now pin so black cannot capture the
piece anyways
I carried out my normal activities so I
first of all hit this measure with the
move c6 and after Bishop to e2 I played
the movie six again hitting the another
Bishop and after Bishop do a four Bishop
to d6 castling on the Kings side I
played the MU King to e7 and it's time
for the assessment black is a clear free
pawn up in the game that is about Bishop
to b4
instead of Bishop to b4 the more
trickier line is looked to be three and
after rook to v3 black has the only
reply laughs which is Queen to d6 and
this line is very very aggressive
because now I can play the move Bishop
to b4 attacking the Queen Queen has a
hint one square which is Queen to b6 and
fortunately this is check and it looks
very very scary when the operand plays
move such as rook to e3 so it's not only
hitting the Queen
but beyond the Queen it's also hitting
the e7 but black has a fantastic reply
which is the move Knight to e4 and now
you can see the downside of whites piece
placements not only black is threatening
to capture these two pieces but this nya
doesn't have any good discoveries and in
the game my opponent doesn't find any
better than the move Bishop to e4
afterwards I simply capture this light
so what's the idea of giving up this
piece well why it's idea was to regain
the piece wire the move f3 but I didn't
allow him first of all I hit this rook
with the move Queen to f6 and my
opponent defined it with the move Queen
to e2 and now I give this check and here
my response is pretty much force white
has to play the move g3 and now I
capture that pawn and can you believe
still black is holding everything and
not only that it's a jacking queen and a
rook so in the game my opponent decided
to play Queen to f2 it looks like black
is in trouble right now because this
bishop is looking at the c6 square and
also this Knight is hanging but a king
like has a very simple reply which is
Queen to f6 and black goes everything
why it cannot capture this night with
the pawn because his own rook is hanging
second is white cannot catch this night
with the Queen because the rook is
hanging and the best part is this Queen
is also protecting the c6 square let's
see how the game finished so here my
opponent is pointed with the move rook
to be one so we desperately want the
piece back or no matter first I
developed my PC so I played rook to b8
attacking the bishop and after Bishop to
c5 now black plays the very ultra sharp
move which is the move Knight which one
and you can see this Knight is attacking
the Queen and if the rook captures then
the same result will happen so in this
game my opponent played Queen to e2
afterwards I simply give the check and
after King to d2 now placket another
piece and the funny thing is this rook
is right now pin so again this eise evan
looks like a weakness but it's all
covered
so that is pretty much you need to know
about Bishop cross see six and nine
cross see six in my next video I am
going to show you in detail what you
should do after pressure to deed